Film Courage: I was looking at another talented
screenwriter’s site and her name is Shelley
Gustavson (via Shelley Gustavson.com).
And she says in this one article “There
are stories that you figure out and then write.
And then there are stories that you figure
out as you write them.”
Any thoughts?
Barrington Smith Seetachitt: Oh…that’s
interesting.
Stories that you figure out and write.
Or stories that you figure out as you write
them...Janice Rhoshalle Littlejohn: I think
that’s true both for my work as a journalist
and a screenwriter.
I can go into an interview believing that
it’s going to go one way and it turns out
to be an entirely new thing.
[This] is a little off topic but I remember
when 9/11 happened and I was supposed to have
interviewed John Schneider at that time.
He was Superman…Barrington Smith Seetachitt:
Father…Janice Rhoshalle Littlejohn: He
was the father of Superman.Barrington Smith
Seetachitt: Smallville.
Janice: Thank you.
For the CW show Smallville.
And we had been trying to get this thing [the
interview] together.
We had cancelled and he was out of town.
And so I contacted his publicists and she
was like “No, he still wants to do it.”
And it was the day that George Bush was delivering
the prayer after 9/11.
I was on the freeway and we still hadn’t
heard from one of my cousins who lived in
New York.
And so I’m just like weeping in the car
and it was just so stressful.
So I pull myself together, I go to his home,
his wife lets me in.
He’s upstairs watching the prayer.
I’m trying to get myself composed and he
comes down and I’ve got journalism face
on and I’m like “Hello, how are you?”
and he’s like “Did you know anybody?”
All I kept thinking was ‘We don’t know
where Barbara is’ and I just broke down.
So what I thought was just going to be this
innocuous personality profile about this actor
turned into a really interesting revealing
story, not only about the character he was
playing but what justice and what patriotism
and all of these things meant.
So a story that was supposed to be this cute
little personality profile about this actor
turned into something deeper and richer.
I talked to my editor about whether or not
I should include that I wept on this man’s
white shirt [laughs].
And so it was one of those things that even
now in the work that we’re doing, we had
a certain focus and idea about it and I think
as we’ve gone through this screenwriting
workshop in Switzerland and the experiences
we’ve had there, just stepping back from
the screenplay for a couple of weeks and then
coming back and just kind of reevaluating
what it is that we’re trying to say and
how are we saying it and are we really affecting
not only good story but are we really saying
something with the way that we’re going.
I think it can happen but I think it can definitely
happen both ways.
I was open to it as a journalist because it
was always fun.
It’s like a discovery when you have preconceptions
of what your story is but then it develops
into something very different.
I think there is something very exciting about
that and something very freeing about it if
you allow yourself to open to that, it can
go in a direction.
Because I think even to a certain extent the
things that we’ve done at least in this
screenplay have moved further from what I
thought my original idea was.
But it’s so much better.
I’m working on a documentary where I thought
I was going to have a particular story that
was going to go in a particular way and time
and finances (because I don’t have the money
to continue to generate it) once it’s done.
I can see it’s already a different story
because there was a particular timeframe on
that story that I thought “Oh, I’m going
to get it done and I’m going to get this
and the personality is going to be great”
and it didn’t turn out that way, you know
[laughs].
And so looking at how that story can evolve
now it’s going to be a…you know the story
I wanted to tell was great.
This story could be even greater because of
not only my experience in time but because
of new circumstances and new developments
and new undertones and things like that.
So I think working with something and having
it be what you thought it was going to be
is great but also the discovery of something
new from what you thought you had is also
a wonderful gift.
Barrington Smith Seetachitt:  I think…yeah…really
if I’m honest, I’m always figuring it
out as I write.
Even if I go in thinking that I know what
it is, I’m still going to end up figuring
it out as I go.
Yeah….[laughs].
I have inside-out writing and outside-in writing
and the outside-in will tend to be something
where there is kind of an external story.
And so you’ve got the container a little
bit and you’re figuring out all of the ways
that you’re furnishing and arranging what’s
in that container and generating some new
stuff.
And occasionally I have the luxury of doing
kind of what I call the inside-out where you
just have almost nothing, where you woke up
in the middle of the night with an image in
your head or just this kind of very fragmentary
thing like a grain of sand and then it’s
like you’re making a narrative stone soup.
You’re like “Here’s the pebble…”
Do you know the story of stone soup?
They go around and get the meat and the carrots
and everything.
Then it’s more like they found art by just
pulling all of the things from your life:
your memories, what’s going on, and you’re
kind of building it out from this little thing
and it becomes something where you really
didn’t have much of an idea of what it was
going to be at all and so that’s pretty
fun.
And that would again be an example of figuring
it out as you go.
Question for the viewers: Do you figure
out your story and then write it?
Or do you figure out your story as you write
it?